we live in strange
times
[Music]
the housing bubble burst rise of china
and the rise of inequality health is a
very big
taxes are front rank issues two groups
have been left behind
but it's a complicated story
[Music]
instead of saying oh it's a complicated
world i don't get it say
all right let me try to figure this out
let me make sense of this
[Music]
doing economics requires stepping back
from all of the details to say what is
the essential here what is the story
it's about people it's not about money
and it ends up being about what people
do
really good economics has a kind of
beauty to it
and it comes down to just two principles
100 bills don't lie in the street very
long
the other is every sale is also a
purchase things add up
what you're going to learn here in this
class is how to think like an economist
healthcare in america is an economic
issue left to its own devices
private health insurance actually just
doesn't work
the crisis of 2008 wasn't as bad as the
great depression
and if you ask why well because we
learned something
it's never been more important to
educate yourself there isn't an
establishment
that knows what it's doing and it's
going to get us through all of this
it's going to have to come from you
there's no guarantee that good ideas
prevail but if you don't try to
have those good ideas and get them out
there then of course they will prevail
keep on plugging and don't let the
crazies grind you down
i'm paul krugman and this is my master
class
you